okay h
Sal
[Silence]
can I speak to you
after you can straighten out the mic can
you do is that okay okay
[Silence]
SM
asbar
[Silence]
ahbar
ASU ASU Allah
[Silence]
ill ASU
asham
[Silence]
Sal
he
[Silence]
allahar
alhamdulillah alhamd
[Silence]
all
dear brothers and sisters in Islam May
the peace mercy and blessings of Allah
Almighty be upon each and every one of
you this beautiful day when We Gather in
this beautiful place in the house of
Allah tal to reflect upon Allah tala to
Express gratitude for all all the
bounties that Allah tal has provided us
to seek forgiveness and to ask for
guidance and help among many other
things alhamdulillah in the Holy Quran
which we Muslims are so fortunate to
have to have access to in the original
Arabic and the original verses that were
sent down to our beloved Prophet s.
wasam 1446 years ago alhamdulillah there
are many different types of ways that
Allah T communicates The Message of
Islam sometimes Allah T tells us
something directly pray just pray
other times Allah T gives us Parables or
or examples and sometimes Allah T gives
us Beautiful Stories because Allah T
knows human beings love stories we love
love stories we've always loved stories
and we'll probably always love stories
until the end of time and so many of
these stories are about very ious
prophets who faced adversity and
challenges during their lifetime and
sometimes the stories are short and
sometimes they're rather detailed and
long and so today we're going to reflect
a little bit upon probably the longest
story in the Quran of a single prophet
and that's Prophet yfam The Prophet
Joseph in Surah 12 so I know I always
give homework when I'm up here that's
your homework for this week try to look
at Surah YF sometime because I'm only
going to have time to talk about a few
of the amazing lessons that are in this
Surah there are so many lessons there's
so many things one can learn from this
Surah I'm only going to focus on a few
of them
in so the first one is the very first
verse in which the in which the Story
begins in which Allah says
[Silence]
sorry we could please turn off our
phones too that would be
wonderful so Allah says remember when
Yousef said to his father his father
being oh Father I dreamt of 11 stars and
the Sun and the Moon I dreamt they were
bowing to me now his father masallah had
great perception great wisdom and what
was his reaction after s Yu said this to
him don't tell your brothers about this
right don't tell your brothers I'm
worried something bad might happen if
you tell your brothers about this they
might be even more envious than they
already were of him and so the first
lesson we get here right at the
beginning of the story is the importance
of Consulting our elders Consulting our
parents right if there's something we're
not really sure about something kind of
strange happens it's okay in fact it's
recommended here to follow the example
of
yfam and to let our parents or someone
we really really trust know about
this before sharing this information or
this dream or this Vision with the
whole world or on social media or some
other way so that's the first lesson we
get right at the beginning of the story
of s
yfam now you all probably know the story
despite not sharing this Vision yousef's
siblings cast him in a well right they
they get rid of him and Yousef alisam
gets picked up from the well he gets
sold into slavery and where does he end
up he ends up in Egypt right in a
prosperous person's house and there he
reaches maturity but what happens when
he reaches maturity he's an extremely
good-look young man right and so we get
our second big lesson or another big
lesson here is the power of physical
attraction I see some young folks here
it happens to older folks too but
especially when you're younger this
power of physical attraction is very
very strong in the Quran Allah
acknowledges this that's how we were
created
right that's how one of the many ways
we're tested is how do we handle this
intense physical attraction that can
occur between and does occur between the
Sexes and
so ultimately the situation grows and
grows and you can read about it and in
your homework I'm not going to go into
the details from the
minbar But ultimately yuam is given an
ultimatum either you do what you're not
supposed to do or go to prison
and here it's
remarkable
[Silence]
saysf
says prison is more attractive to me
then what what this woman is summoning
me to do prison prison is more
attractive to me and he evinces a real
concern that he doesn't know if he
doesn't go to prison how long he can
hold out because of all the intense
pressure that's going to be him on him
trapped trapped in this house and so
that is the reason YF Alam goes to
prison he didn't do anything wrong in
fact ironically the reason he went to
prison is because he didn't do something
wrong right that's that's why he us went
to prison cuz he didn't do the wrong
thing he didn't commit the crime and he
ended up m going to prison for a period
of time and after a while he gets
released you can read all about that in
Surah yusf and we get another lesson
which is related very closely to that
power of physical attraction between
males and females between men and women
because as he's released either he or
the wife of his owner it's ambiguous who
said this but it's a very important
statement Allah T says and puts this in
the mouth of either the wife of aiz or
in the mouth of YF
[Silence]
in this ay Allah T says or I do not puts
quotes either yfam or the wife of aiz
saying I do not declare my soul innocent
the soul ever urges to evil except when
my Lord shows Mercy truly my Lord is all
forgiving all
merciful now Allah in his infinite mercy
and generosity identifies three types of
souls in the Quran itself in the
Quran and this is the first one that
gets identified if you start from the
beginning of the book of Allah and work
your way through it and
S right the soul that urges to evil this
is the the Locust of anger sensual
desires and it's the one that constantly
is in need of Restraint of discipline
and of it's often described as the
blameworthy soul now the soul can be
confusing we're not going to try to
explain every detail of the Soul here
I'm just going to focus on the three
states that a soul can be in according
to the Holy Quran according to Allah tal
and the lowest of the the states is
the that is the lowest and that's the
most tough most difficult to control a
spiritual Master almost a thousand years
ago wrote this following or taught the
following lesson and it is just as
applicable today I think as it was back
900 years ago in Baghdad he wrote the
signs of this Soul are greed and pursuit
of carnal desires and Pleasures as soon
as it gratifies one desire it goes after
another belittling it's what it the
blessings it already possesses such as
food drink clothing spouse dwelling and
means of Transport are these all
blessings we still have today these are
the things and do we still sometimes say
wish had a better car a better house
or better this or better that right this
is the same same that's
the that's driving us to do that that
which requires control and that Allah
tal warns us about and introduces us to
in Surah yusf now the second type of
Soul we don't run into
until says
this is the this is the blaming soul the
reproachful soul this is the soul that
says man why didn't you wake up the pray
fure right what happened your alarm went
off you turned it off you had snooze
three times what's wrong right
the is happy you missed f it doesn't
care that's great good job right but the
is what gets us into shape that's how
our progress on the path of drawing
closer to Allah tal acting in a way that
is pleasing to Allah tal that is from
the so we should never
underestimate that aspect of the soul
and this is what inshallah will help us
all increase in our closeness and our
Iman
toal and then the highest level of soul
the aspirational soul which is very very
hard to get to right is called the the
Tranquil Soul this is in at the end
of says
Allah refers to the Tranquil soul the
soul that's at peace that's the
aspiration that's what human beings
excuse me that's what human beings are
supposed to aim for that's how we were
created with all these possibilities
with all different three possibilities
but the highest form and
we ask all to give us strength and
guidance to draw closer and ever closer
to that state so that's the third
lesson about our
soul that we have a soul and that it can
be in one or three different sort of
situations according to the Holy Quran a
fourth lesson which I only came across
recently is that after yam was freed
from prison and why was he freed from
prison he interpreted the King's dream
the King was impressed right and instead
of just saying thank you for freeing
from prison I'm going to go into the
desert and just pray and have a nice
time what did yuam say he said to the
King
right at told the king appoint me over
the storehouses right there was going to
be a need if the people of Egypt were
going to survive you needed a good
leader who would control the granaries
make sure there was enough food stored
during the good years so that when the
drought and other challenges came there
was plenty of food and YF recognized
Alam that he was someone who could do
this and so he felt an obligation to say
hey appoint me to do this and then he
said right this is an emphatic form of
Arabic he said I am truly a careful
guardian and very
knowledgeable and so two subtle points
come out of this a if according to many
of the Muslim Scholars who came long
before us right the first is that they
said wait a minute the king is he a
monotheist probably not probably a
polytheist and do kings often do bad
things yeah they often do right no
matter where they are so why does Yousef
want to work and put himself in a
situation for someone who's probably
got some not so Savory things on his
hands and so they understood this to
mean that it's okay to work for a ruler
or presumably any ruler any boss even if
they aren't the most Pious person as
long as you are doing that in order to
increase Justice in the world as long as
you're doing it to increase Justice to
restore rights that have been taken or
in the case of YF alisam he was doing
this to try to prevent massive famine
which would result in a horrible
horrible situation and so this as long
as one's intentions are good working in
a potentially morally compromising
situation which certainly in many parts
if not most of the world people find
themselves in that situation quite
frequently as long as one's intention is
good and one is constantly working
towards the betterment of society and
the people around them then the scholars
say this is a lesson we can derive from
this from this Ayah of in the story
of Surah
Yousef and then the final one final
point I'd to touch on after you
know there's a long back and forth
between YF and his brothers and all
during the famine then ultimately what
happens yfam reveals himself as Yousef
as the brother that his 10 other
brothers had cast into a well many many
years earlier right and so you might say
oh this is a chance when he's going to
get revenge right he's really going to
get revenge on his brothers but what
does he do
instead he says something remarkable
quotes him as
saying Subhan Allah Subhan Allah after
all those years and the horrible things
his brothers did to him what did YF
alisam say he said said no blame shall
fall on you today Subhan Allah what was
youse of looking to do to bring his
family back together and that was his
one request bring bring my father my
father hasn't seen me in a very very
long time right bring bring my family
we're going to move out of the land of
Canaan and bring them here to Egypt
right and so this wasn't the time for
revenge or settling scores and of course
Yousef is a prophet Alam so he has
extraordinary abilities but I think it's
a great lesson nonetheless on the
importance
of doing whatever we can to bring our
families together to keep our families
together and in the event God forbid
Strife or something is happen that
serious to give us the strength to
forgive our family members when the
opportunity arises so we covered only
five of many many possible lessons from
Surah yussef as I said that's your
homework this week please try to
check out the Surah and reflect upon
it and if you find five more let me know
that's great if you find 10 more
masallah there are lots and lots of
lessons in there we talked about the
value of Consulting parents we talked
about the dangers of physical attraction
between the Sexes we talked about the
states of the Soul we talked about
Muslims working for corrupt or morally
compromised people and we talked about
the importance of bringing family
together and these are kind of specific
lessons and I think they tie into much
bigger lessons about some of the core
virtues and values of Islam the value of
forgiveness the value of steadfastness
we didn't even talk about yah Alam and
his steadfastness his hope that he was
going to see his son again at least his
son Yousef
again and the importance of trust in
Allah tole that even when things are
looking very very bad and it's not hard
to find situations where things are
looking very very bad we have to have
faith and trust in Allah that things
will get better there's a purpose for
all this and as long as we keep doing
the best we can and not
despair things will in fact get better
[Silence]
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah
Brothers if you could please come
forward a bit mallah we have a great
great attendance today so I see a
fair number of gaps in the front for
doing that so none of our brothers have
to wait outside in a rather warm
Courtyard
alhamdulillah Allah T doesn't just tell
us about the three types of soul in the
Holy Quran Allah also gives us guidance
for how to control the soul how to
discipline it and there's a very
beautiful verse in
anab anab meaning the Surah of the
spider in which Allah says
[Silence]
Allah says in this beautiful Surah
recite what has been revealed to you
he's addressing our beloved Prophet
[Arabic recitation]
recite what has been addressed to you
and uphold the prayer truly prayer
repels debauchery and vice it repels
wrongdoing the remembrance of Allah the
vocation of Allah is the greatest of
devotions and Allah knows all that you
do so in just these few Clauses we have
tremendous guidance Allah tal is telling
us if we uphold our prayers our Salah
that is already going to help us command
what is good and forbid what is wrong
and then in those times between Salah
which can be quite long right Allah T
tells us there something even better
which is right the remembrance of Allah
tal the invocation of Allah tal that's
something we can do at any time right
that's something we can do anytime we're
awake so Allah T is guiding us here
these two ways Salah and as ways to help
us improve our character to become more
and more to become closer and closer to
Allah tal and then finally Allah reminds
us Allah knows everything we
do everything we do Allah tal knows
right what we do what we think we're
doing privately Allah T knows and that's
a very helpful reminder and hopefully
inspiration for us to keep that in mind
and do the best that we can we ask
Allah to guide us we ask Allah tal to
increase Us in forgiveness to increase
Us in steadfastness and to increase Us
in trust in Allah
Tal Ford
[Silence]
illu
allahar ill
[Silence]
just stuff
allahar
[Silence]
alhamdulillah
for
[Silence]
for for
allahar allahar
allahar
Allah Allah
ald
[Silence]
Miss allahar
allar
allahar allahar
[Silence]
allahar heavens
as
[Silence]
brothers and sisters asalam
alikum first I want to
thank our beloved scholar here Dr Scott
Lucas for taking the time for giving us
a wonderful lecture and inshallah we'll
continue benefiting from your
knowledge and your experience in
the in the IM circles
now continue with that inshallah
we'll be hosting an Imam next week Imam
Muhammad Shadi and the detail of his
visit will be posted in our on our
website so inshallah please keep take a
note of it and try to be here for next
inshallah to benefit from his presence
also the school has started and we
have the preschool to the fourth grade
all classes are in session alhamdulillah
and if you have a child in that age
bracket please talk to brother ahed ja
for a possible placement in that school
we also are looking for the elementary
school teachers so if you have somebody
who may be interested please pass the
word along and please donate generously
on the way out
I it it's
[Silence]
that I'm take my